ahora bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 después de
más de 480 millones de kilómetros y tras
haber viajado por el espacio durante
unos siete meses el pasado jueves 18 de
febrero el rover perciben es de la nasa
aterrizó con éxito el martes a martes o
como se dice técnicamente en una
histórica misión que los científicos
están describiendo como la más ambiciosa
de las que eeuu ha enviado al planeta
rojo y nos acompaña una de las mentes
que está detrás de estas misiones las
que están puestas a los ojos de todo el
mundo saludamos a helio moriyón él es
ingeniero de pruebas y operaciones de
presión en helio muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en france 24 mil gracias
por la invitación guste estar aquí que
usted buen primer lugar preguntarle cuál
es su trabajo en esta histórica misión y
cómo está viviendo esta experiencia
claro durante los últimos cinco años ha
sido un ingeniero de pruebas me he
dedicado a hacer las pruebas de los
diferentes subsistemas aquí en los
modelos terrestres que tenemos de
preservantes
lo que hacemos es básicamente comprobar
que todo lo que hemos diseñado funciona
de manera de manera adecuada y no sólo
eso si encontramos algún tipo de
problema con el software lo tratamos de
arreglar antes del lanzamiento que
ocurrió el año pasado y también de
acuerdo a lo que vamos experimentando en
el espacio durante la trayectoria al
igual que ya en la superficie de marte
si toca arreglar algo lo tratamos de
comprobar aquí en la tierra primero
antes de implementarlo en previamente
así que eso es más o menos lo que me
dedicaba particularmente con un enfoque
en los mecanismos en el control de
motores y en con las imágenes ciertas de
las cámaras que quedan ahora proveído
varias de las fotos que han visto pues
la he trabajado durante los últimos años
elio y cuáles son los objetivos
concretos y principales no de la misión
del ver si behrens
claro tenemos algunos muy importantes y
todos yo creo que muy fascinantes el que
el que más le interesa al público
obviamente esa búsqueda de rastros de
vida durante los últimos desde los años
70 la nasa lleva presencia en el planeta
rojo y poco a poco hemos ido
desarrollando
el conocimiento de lo que hay en la
superficie hemos confirmado agua que en
algún momento existió líquida hoy
existen primordialmente congelada y
también que hay material orgánico lo que
queremos determinar obviamente es que si
ese material orgánico es producto de
alguna de algún evento geológico o si
hay algún tipo de o en algún momento si
hubo algún evento biológico y bueno con
eso vamos a ir en búsqueda de esos
rastros tenemos varios instrumentos que
nos van a ayudar con el tema también
vamos a seguir obviamente estudiando la
geología local al igual que la atmósfera
y el clima también vamos con esas
muestras que sean lo suficientemente
interesantes las vamos a recoger del
suelo vamos a colectar piedras
vamos a almacenarla para que en algún
futuro de aquí pienso yo en una década
menos una década varios otra misión a
recoger esas muestras es devolver a la
tierra
obviamente precedieron es el robot más
avanzado que se ha enviado a marte pero
también es limitado verdad porque no
podemos enviar todos los instrumentos
que quisiéramos así que
volver a esas muestras el planeta tierra
los equipos de científicos del mundo van
a poder experimentar y de manera más
conclusión a determinar que estamos
observando y por último
el objetivo de contribuir a la
arquitectura humana vamos a en algún
momento a enviar astronautas al planeta
rojo y para eso pues tenemos que
entender cómo sobrevivir en la
superficie uno de los instrumentos se
llaman box y va a convertir ese dióxido
de carbono que es el componente
primordial de la atmósfera de marte en
oxígeno que se utilizaría para
obviamente los humanos que pueden
respirar y también para poder crear ese
combustible que necesitarían para
regresar a casa
hablaba justamente de esta tecnología
experimental que están utilizando ahora
ustedes de este instrumento que es el
mox sino que produce oxígeno a partir de
dióxido de carbono o sea que se está
generando oxígeno en la propia
superficie de marte no es todo sería un
paso para una futura presencia humana el
yo
claro es exactamente el punto ya que
obviamente sería mucho más costoso
enviar sean tanques de oxígeno o agua
que se utilice para convertirla nos
conviene mucho más simplemente
implementar estos instrumentos en la
superficie de marte para tener por decir
una fábrica de oxígeno para que los
astronautas puedan sobrevivir de manera
larga o sea estar en presencia por
muchos años
ahora las imágenes enviadas hasta el
momento ellos están siendo evaluadas por
ustedes los científicos de la nasa que
nos dicen hasta el momento estos
hallazgos
claro espero que hayan visto esta semana
obviamente llevamos solamente una semana
en la superficie nos hemos enfocado más
que nada en lo que ha sido el
asegurarnos que todo esté funcionando
poco a poco asegurarnos que cada
subsistema funciona de la manera
adecuada y con las imágenes que hemos
tomado a bordo confirmar exactamente
dónde estamos en el cráter yesero y no
sólo eso por primera vez hemos retornado
imágenes del descenso algo que nunca se
ha visto por vídeo que lo que para mí
fue espectacular para el equipo entero
si en base a todo a todo no sólo la
cabeza que sabíamos exactamente lo que
iba a ocurrir los aspectos técnicos pero
nunca lo habíamos visto porque nunca se
había grabado es la segunda vez que
utilizamos el sky koren mujer
anteriormente fue con el curiosity que
llegó en el 2012 y ahora con un
precedente y bueno de cierta manera el
robot verdad es una extensión de
nosotros los seres humanos verdad ahora
con
nuestros ojos y con nuestros oídos
porque también hay dos micrófonos a
bordo que nunca se ha hecho en un robot
que llegaba martes pues tenemos ahora
nuestras de cierta manera a nuestra
presencia en el planeta rojo y lo
podemos vivir con el rojo como decíamos
el yo la misión está poniendo está
implementando tecnologías de punta que
tiene la nasa que es pionera tecnología
es pionera por supuesto el robot cuenta
por ejemplo con el helicóptero internet
y en el cual usted precisamente estuvo
trabajando cuéntenos de qué se trata
ha sido un gran honor ser parte del
equipo de newbery y ahora en el equipo
de los pilotos que vamos a empezar a
volar
ya que algunos meses estén pendientes de
las redes sociales de sobre el tema por
primera vez de la humanidad va a volar
un helicóptero fuera del planeta tierra
esto nunca se ha logrado ay me encanta
recalcar verdad que solamente hace un
poquito más de 100 años estábamos recién
aprendiendo a volar y una vez aquí en el
planeta tierra y ahora estamos en el
2021 y vamos a volar en el planeta rojo
es un gran honor ser parte de ese equipo
y pendientes porque la razón por la cual
lo vamos a hacer es para demostrar que
esta tecnología se puede implementar en
marte para que así en alguna manera en
el futuro en vez de enviar roberts o
aterrizador es
enviamos helicópteros o drones y así
podemos pues tener un cierto aspecto
nuevo o una visión aérea de lo que es el
planeta rojo y también para los
astronautas para que tengan acompañantes
en un futuro ahora también otra pregunta
que surge no y que interesa a muchísimas
personas tiene que ver con que se espera
que muestras marcianas tomadas por
perseveran sean enviadas a la tierra
como van a hacer esto
claro estamos trabajando en una misión
que le sigue y al verse bien es que les
cuento de aquí hace una década más o
menos estaremos hablando más sobre el
tema y es en colaboración con la agencia
europea así que estamos trabajando
muchas organizaciones a nivel mundial
ir a retornar ciertas muestras que sean
lo suficientemente importantes el
subsistema más capaz robótico que hemos
enviado al espacio está en percibir que
es el que va a conectar estas muestras y
las va a guardar y almacenar dentro del
robot y así de cierta manera de aquí en
los siguientes dos años vamos a
determinar dónde vamos a soltar esas
muestras para que una misión le siga y
esa esa misión también va a ser una de
las más ambiciosas en la historia porque
va a tener que lanzarse de la tierra
viajar por el espacio llegar a marte
después de eso recolectar las muestras
lanzar un cohete de marc desde marte que
nunca se ha hecho otro orbitador tendría
que colectar esa muestra desde la órbita
y devolverlo a casa y debe entrar a la
atmósfera de la tierra así que muy
ambiciosa la misión y también va a ser
muy fans muy fascinante de aquí a la
siguiente década él y usted hablaba
previamente no de la búsqueda de vida de
qué tipo de vida se estaban pensando
claro misma pregunta estamos buscando
vida microscópica los científicos y los
expertos han concluido que si vamos a
encontrar algo o algún tipo de rastro de
vida antigua pues va a ser microscópica
y ya tenemos como les cuento evidencia
de que existió en algún momento agua
líquida en el planeta particularmente en
el cráter de cero se podrán imaginar el
desemboque de un río si van a cualquier
desemboque de un río en cualquier parte
del mundo pueden recoger una piedra y la
pueden partir por la mitad se van a dar
cuenta que muchas de estas piedras pues
tienen estas diferentes capas que son
materiales que han sido depositados a lo
largo de los miles y millones de años y
aquí en la tierra pues es muy evidente
para los científicos donde exactamente
hay procesos que involucran vida
microscópica a lo largo de los millones
de millones de años así que con ese
conocimiento vamos en búsqueda de
similares muestras en el cráter yesero
ahora lo cuáles son las principales
dificultades que han experimentado y que
se pueden experimentar para llevar
humanos a marte
bueno se podrán imaginar un viajecito
siete meses por el espacio para llegar a
marte entre una cápsula muy pequeña es
muy difícil yo personalmente no me
imagino estar encerrado por tanto tiempo
para entrar en un planeta de una manera
muy relativamente violenta como lo hizo
percibir events es mucho más fácil
explorar de manera robótica por eso
cuando vamos a enviar humanos pues vamos
a tener mucho más cuidado en el proceso
que se utiliza para el despegue de la
tierra el viaje por el espacio al igual
que la entrada y bueno todo esto nada es
oficial verdad así que veremos cuando
ocurre personalmente pienso que de aquí
a 20 años lo vamos a ver el yo
mauricio ha sido un placer dialogar por
ustedes muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24